I'd like very much for you to uh give a
a warm welcome to Rosaline Talon who
been very
wel
all I would like to thank all of you for
coming here and having an interest in
this awful thing that's affecting our
families once again Ground
Zero my only brother a New York City
firefighter and US Marine died nine
years ago for his country at the World
Trade Center my brother's name was Shan
he was a fair-haired handsome strong
26-year-old man who had graduated
college
served his country as a US Marine
reservist served his city as an
emergency medical technician and was
finishing up his probationary year in
the
FDNY he was living at home with my
parents and saving some money hoping to
find a good girl to settle down with he
would have made a great dad he was the
Perfect Blend of strength and
sensitivity he wore his heart on his
sleeve and was an honest and helpful
confidence on he was also a real Wise
Guy the guys from his Marine platoon had
tons of great on liners that they
remembered from Shan they said he was
always able to lighten the mood with a
witty comment or a wise crack proud of
his Irish heritage Shawn played great
Irish Jigs and Reels on the button
accordion he and my dad together were
longsuffering fans of the New York Mets
Jets and
Rangers he loved New York and he loved
loved cruising down to work on the West
Side Highway down to the tenous Shan's
Firehouse was the firehouse of the World
Trade
Center so that morning we knew where sha
was my dad was working right across the
East River in Brooklyn he had a clear
view of the smoking North Tower he knew
Shan's Firehouse would have been first
due to the scene he pictured sha
climbing up within that Tower my dad
watched a second plane hit the South
Tower like us all he knew that this was
no accident this was an
attack he watched both Towers fall his
son crushed within my dad knew that his
only son the son who had made him so
proud had just been
demolished yes I say demolished I
stopped by my mom's house yesterday to
look in the medical examiner's
report in order for you to fully
understand a 911 family member
perspective on the slated Ground Zero
mosque I must allow you to walk in our
shoes for a moment you will hear from
other moms today I wanted to share with
you the raw details my mother had to
read about her son when he was
identified sha P
Talon torso and
extremities head
absent reddish arm hair multiple spine
fra fractures pelvic fracture legs
fractured knees dislocated ankles
fractured and dislocated right hand
missing received in separate bag head
and broken helmet eyes not present
decomposing possessions Radio Bunker
Pants and Jacket Sean P Talon written on
them path mark discount card extra-
large blue shirt with Talent embroidered
on it and the certified first respond
patch on the shoulder blue boxer shorts
blue work shorts boots and two white
socks I begged my mom not to look at
Sean before we waked him I could not
bear her last memory of him to be a
decomposed broken headless form I wanted
her last memory of him to be the morning
of September 11th when he wore his green
rugby shirt that he had bought on his
trip to Ireland with my parents 10 days
before 911
I wanted her to remember how he had
asked her with a grin where he could
find a good Irish soda bread for the
firehouse because a Jewish firefighter
had busted his chops about the last one
he took in she told him the Italian
bakery down the street made the best
Irish soda bread for the Jewish guy in
the
firehouse that was the Sha I wanted her
to remember however being a mother now
myself I understand why she wanted to to
touch his broken demolished body one
more
time that was her
child Shawn was killed in the name of
Islam he was killed because he was
considered an Infidel the people who
killed him recited verses from the Quran
as they slam jetliners into our World
Trade Center before 9/11 I had never any
reason to think about the Muslim
religion I never read about the Quran I
never knew I was an Infidel I never knew
about Kaa or the Taliban after 9911 I
hoped that we would be able to capture
Osama and the Taliban and stop al-
Qaeda however I still never delved into
the Muslim religion never sought revenge
against the Muslim terrorists never
called for investigations of mosques my
family picked up the pieces of Our Lives
worked hard to keep Sha's memory alive
we also became involved in trying to
ensure a place of honor at Ground Zero
we have become involved in several
Endeavors in this front we were part of
an effort to try to get the Twin Towers
rebuilt unfortunately that will not be
the case just one Tower is being
constructed we were involved in
imploring that the rescue workers be
listed on the memorial with their
firefighter or police officer rank
rather than just the name unfortunately
King Bloomberg will not allow such a
Preposterous thing
King Bloomberg's Memorial consists of
two giant waterfalls and sunken pools
depicting the footprints initially there
was going to be no placement of the
names of the dead at street level they
were going to be placed under street
level under the pools we were involved
in getting the names out from
underground and into the light they will
be now placed around the waterfalls at
street level can you believe we had to
fight for
this the latest insult is that the
911 museum will be seven stories
underground and the museum has decided
to take all the unidentified human
remains from the office of the medical
examiner and use them as a programmable
element in the museum they will be
placed at the very bottom of the museum
seven stories below street level that is
where loved ones who never bought their
loved ones home will go to visit that is
our latest struggle we want those
remains out of the basement Museum and
given the separate distinct dignity that
they deserve and it is against this
backdrop this 9911 Memorial backdrop
that we family members heard the news
that a $100 million mosque was being
planned to soar at Ground Zero sounded
like a joke at first why would anyone
want to antagonize Ground Zero like that
ground zero is sacran to New Yorker and
to all Americans hallowed by the
sacrifice of those innocent victims If
This Were February 2002 would it be okay
for a mosque to be built at Ground Zero
I don't think so but what has changed
nothing has changed Ground Zero will
always be Ground Zero those who support
this mosque hide behind the developers
obvious right to build the mosque but
they do not address whether this is the
right thing to do however it is about
what is the right thing to do to respect
those who were murdered and the site
where we were attacked this is not about
bigotry my brother would have saved
Muslim Christian or Jew in those towers
that day he was not a bigot nor am I
this is about decency and a shared
understanding of the painful memories of
our Common Man it is painful for my
mother to think about how her son was
murdered she cannot pretend that the
people who killed her son were not
Muslim this crime was not perpetrated by
all Muslim people but it was perpetrated
by some Muslim people and instead of
leaving Ground Zero to heal without
conflict the developers want a mosque
there to Worship in along with a special
Islamic cultural center that caters to
Muslim interests with Halal food in the
cafeteria and Halal cooking lessons a
daycare for Muslim children Arabic
language classes and all this right on
the precipice of Slaughter by Islamic
jihadists Ground Zero is not a place to
celebrate Muslim culture it is a place
to remember those killed by Islamic
Terror Ground Zero is not a place for a
quick swim and a nice Halal lunch while
the children are learning their Arabic
and celebrating Islam if this atrocity
had been perpetrated by some some Irish
terrorists I would be ashamed at any
proposal to build an Irish Cultural
Center and a church there I would not
think that Irish dancing lessons in a
corn beef and cabbage sandwich would be
respectful at Ground Zero had 911 being
carried out by Irish I know there are
many Muslim Americans that feel this way
too but I guess they're too afraid to
speak out so far the developers have
fired two imams from the ground zero MOS
board both of these imams had become a
liability to the project due to their
controversial and radical statements it
will be difficult for the developers to
appoint an Imam who is not radical to
their board because it is very radical
to place a mosque at Ground
Zero New York has churches synagogue
dogs and mosqu all coexisting in peace
we are a very tolerant City already the
supporters of this mosque keep saying
that we are not being tolerant actually
the antagonistic move to place a mega
mosque near where men women and children
were slaughtered is not tolerant of our
country's basic sensitivities respect
for our hero dead tolerance begins with
respect where is the mosque developers
and supporters tolerance of America's
tradition of honoring her hero dead and
the battlefields they fell on my brother
was an American hero and that day Ground
Zero was an American Battlefield this is
not about rights this is about respect
my parents were immigrants from Ireland
they made the great United States of
America their country and raised their
son to love and respect her so much so
that he signed on the dotted line to
give his life for her if need be I think
the developers and suppor ERS of this
Ground Zero mosque need to take a page
from that book they need to take a page
about respecting one's country and the
Traditions that citizens hold dear such
as honoring her hero dead not rubbing
salt in a wound that will continue to
heal for
Generations I know as conservative
Americans we have numerous battlefronts
none so dear to me as the pro-life
movement however just as with the
pro-life movement and other conservative
issues the ground zero mosque begs your
attention it is another issue of respect
it is an issue of respect for the dead
the same in respect and dignity accorded
to the dead and Ground Zero back in 2001
is the same respect they deserve now and
always thank you very
much
thank you rosalene now I wish uh I want
you to hear from Sally Reagan har lost
her 28-year-old son Christian